en 2010 je travaillais dans le marketing
en Espagne pour une grande
multinationale
un jour le président demande à me voir
c'était pas habituel dans une grande
entreprise on ne traite pas directement
avec le président
j'ai un peu peur de faire un rendez-vous
et quand on a peur on imagine toujours
le pire
alors j'arrive et il me dit
Sylvia je voudrais qu'à partir de
maintenant tu t'occupes du bonheur
je me démence si c'est une façon
élégante de me licencier
vous voyez à la maison d'autant plus que
quand j'arrive à la maison les enfants
me disent mais maman ce n'est pas un
travail on ne peut pas être directrice
du bonheur parce que le bonheur on ne le
commande pas
pourquoi
un grand patron d'une grande entreprise
veut-il que je m'occupe du bonheur
mais il était visionnaire il avait
compris avant beaucoup d'autres
que nos émotions sont à l'origine des
nodécision tout consommateur va décider
avec ses émotions et nous tous
dans mes voici je deviens experte à
l'émotion et de tous ces parcours j'ai
appris une chose que je vais partager
avec vous
on décide on innove avec nos émotions
pas un sel c'est une question de choisir
les bons émotions au bon moment
que ça soit des élèves des employés des
consommateurs des clients
votre oncle et même votre banquier il
décide tous avec leurs émotions
et innover c'est décidé
quand on Innov on décide de faire
quelque chose différemment
ou de faire une chose que personne
d'autre n'a fait auparavant
donc il faut décider et innover avec nos
émotions
mais il y a des émotions qui vont faire
qu'on puisse avoir accès aux parties les
plus créatives aux parties qui
connaissent qui sont qui nous amènent à
être des Saliers et des vrais saluer
pour des décisions et des innovations et
il y a des émotions qui vont nous couper
de tous ces capacités et qui sont moins
intéressantes pour une nouvelle
quelle est la pire de ces émotions quand
on veut innover créer
la pire c'est la peur
voyons c'est que sous la peur va envoyer
a décidé de faire quand il devait
innover et prendre une décision complexe
le premier avril
rongwayne est au travail et deux de ses
collègues viennent le voir et lui disent
de rentrer dans leur toute petite
aventure pour innover dans les
ordinateurs
accepte princesse économie des 800
dollars et investi dans cette entreprise
alléchant de 10% des parts
il crée même le premier logo de cette
aventure ces deux collègues
s'appelle Steve Jobs
il a créé une pomme pour faire Apple et
Steve Jobs qui n'a peur de rien 12 jours
après que rentre dans l'entreprise fait
le premier contrat de la toute nouvelle
Apple avec le premier client
ce client c'est un client local connu de
tout le monde pour être un très très
mauvais payeur alors Ron toujours après
avoir pris départ prends peur il décider
rendre les parts et de partir récupérer
ces 800 dollars
il aurait aujourd'hui 35 milliards alors
qu'il a bien pris sa retraite normale il
y a très peu de temps ah oui la peur
c'est pas la bonne émotion pour plein de
décision complexe dont innover la peur
c'est une émission émotion puissante
utile mais elle nous fiche une nouvelle
paralysée où elle nous fait fuir alors
c'est le contraire de ceux dont on a
besoin quand on innove la peur va nous
faire rester dans ce qu'on connaît bien
contourner les problèmes
de l'avant rencontre des problèmes
gravir des montagnes
on ne peut pas innover avec la peur
si ce n'est pas la peur alors quels sont
les meilleures émotions quand on veut
innover
les meilleurs innovations commencent
tous en toute quand ce qui mettent dans
des émotions dans les conditions qui
sont qui le font sentir bien qui sont
positives la confiance en soi en leur
idée dans l'autre les autres l'équipe
les émotions positives qui font de nous
sentir bien encourager plein d'énergie
c'est ce type d'émotion qui laisse votre
petit grain des folie émerger et croire
en ce qui est encore impossible parce
que quand on innove on est encore
fragile au début les idées ne sont pas
encore solide
et donc quelqu'un peut les faire tomber
facilement
faisons un exercice pour innover un
nourrissant tout est possible étant
positive et croyant à nous prénom le
problème de réchauffement climatique et
en Europe
le réchauffement climatique est dû à un
grand parti à cause de ses missions CO2
61% de ces émotions
émotion émission proviennent des
voitures de voyage en voiture privée et
85% de ses voyages sont faits par des
gens des voitures où il y a une seule
personne dedans
donc voilà nous savons le cadre donc si
nous pensons vraiment en étant positif
croyant à nous on nous dit ça voilà
comment faire une idée où les gens
pourraient prendre un moyen de transport
rapide facile à côté des cheveux pas
cher du tout et qui n'est contamine pas
du tout dans leur
et je voulais dire les premières minutes
univers sont dures on peut la balayer
n'est-ce pas
mais je vous salue qu'il faut croire en
vous un vautrisé ce que vous allez
accomplir vous voulez un moyen d'être un
sport beaucoup moins polluant facile mon
volet mais plus facile qu'un avion si
vous restez positif sur cette idée vous
la verrez transformée en 2013 par Elon
Musk dans ce qui on appelle le projet
hyperloop qu'est-ce que sont les super
loop c'est la même idée que vous avez vu
les transformer ces décapsules qui vont
l'éviter grâce à des champs
électromagnétiques et qui vont pouvoir
vous transporter à plus de 1000 km heure
avec trois fois moins de pollution
imaginez-vous faire Toulouse Malaga
mineur avec une fraction de la pollution
donc si vous restez positif si vous
dites tout est possible vous pouvez
vraiment innover vraiment ramener des
idées complètement nouvelle et
impatiente
mais ceci est tellement tellement
attirant comme il était tellement
logique de rester positive et de croire
en nous que beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
restaient là
hélas
85 déjà très preneurs des innovateurs
n'ont pas de succès dans avec leur
innovations pourquoi parce que juste
après avoir été vraiment confiante dans
nous à nos idées il faut changer les
fusils d'épaule et de venir l'avocat du
diable il faut anticiper tout ce qui
pourrait mal se passer bien avant qu'on
soit avec des problèmes que la peur
arrive quand on est en pleine possession
de tous nos capacités il faut prendre le
temps de se plonger dans tout ce qui
pourrait mal se passer
ceci a aussi une autre avantage
émotionnellement quand on anticipe qui
est innover c'est rencontrer plein de
problèmes
on va être préparé et quand ces
problèmes vont arriver on ne va pas
perdre courage on gardera notre énergie
concentré sur les solutions et sur
Avancées on trouvera ça normal
donc on a parlé de changer de positif ou
négatif et pourtant beaucoup beaucoup
d'innovateurs ne le font pas laissez-moi
vous raconter une autre grande
innovation de notre siècle
on va à 1912 quand les constructeurs de
Titanic annoncent qui sont construits un
bateau une innovation incroyable parce
que c'est le premier bateau absurde
confiance optimiste les bateaux
commencent le premier voyage le 14 avril
1912 un bateau prévient le Titanic qu'il
va rencontrer des glaces plus tard mais
le capitaine elle doit assmis reste
optimiste et malgré les avertissements
il annule le XS l'exercice qui était
prévu ce dimanche pour essayer de
sauvetage
il préfère que les gens puissent aller à
la messe
le soir
le Titanic heart aniceberg alors le
service de sauvetage doit se faire et
les gens mettent dans les canaux de
sauvetage entre 20 et 40 personnes alors
que ces canaux de sauvetage sont
préparés pour accueillir 70 au moins
résultat de ses manques de préparation
pour ce scénario le pire seulement 711
passagers seront sauvés et plus de 1500
vont mourir dans l'essuie
il faut se préparer au pire scénario
avant que ça arrive quand on est encore
en pleine possession de tous nos
capacités tranquilles optimistes il faut
se préparer
c'est pas une question de ne pas savoir
d'être émotions c'est une question
justement de quand les utiliser les bons
émotions au bon moment et c'est ceci que
quatre étudiants de cette assumer en
fait en 2008 quand il rencontrait en
parlant les mêmes problèmes pour
s'acheter des nouvelles lunettes
les quatre étudiants ne pouvaient pas se
payer de nouvelles lunettes aux
États-Unis en 2008
il y avait une entreprise qui détenait
80% des marchés
depuis que cette entreprise produit ses
lunettes jusqu'au moment où vous les
saviez entre vos mains il y avait
tellement d'intervenants qui ajoutaient
leurs marches qu'à la fin la paire des
lunettes revenait en moyenne à 500 euros
trop cher pour les étudiants pour
telennes lunettes il y avait un étudiant
qui avait les lunettes avec la branche
accrochée par un trombone
ils se sont dit ce nuit là on va se
mettre dans les meilleures conditions on
y croit c'est nous qui allons résoudre
le problème des lunettes cher en
États-Unis c'est nous comment on fait et
se sont dit
prénom
Lucine et un voyant directement les
lunettes au consommateur éliminant tous
les intervenants
c'est internet
donc ils sont CROUS
en leur idée c'était eux qui seraient
capables ils sont même calculés que il
pourrait vendre les lunettes au lieu de
le vendre à 500 euros à 95
l'idée est née histoire d'automne alors
comme beaucoup d'innovateurs et
d'étudiants ils vont voir les proches
les familles et ils disent on a une idée
on veut vendre des lunettes beaucoup
moins chères par internet et il se
reçoivent quoi
ça ne marchera
et si c'était une idée qui était bonne
intéressante quelqu'un d'autre l'aurait
fait voilà donc il reste à ça mais ils
savent qu'il faut rester positifs qui
croient à leur idée donc qui s'accroche
et juste après ils se disent mais
maintenant on va se préparer à tout ce
qui pourrait mal se passer on va
anticiper ils prennent deux ans
à tout ce qui pourrait mal se passer
d'abord ils se disent et si ils sont
raison et c'est pas une bonne idée on ne
va pas arrêter nos études il continue à
étudier alors qu'il devait l'idée
ils se disent aussi c'est vrai que
personne n'a jamais vendu des lunettes
par Internet avant et si les gens
n'achètaient pas parce que ils ne
peuvent pas les essayer car ils prennent
le temps et ils créent le premier
service au monde où on peut commander
les lunettes cinq paires les recevoir
gratuitement les essayer si on aime on
n'aime pas on peut le rendre assez
recours c'est un risque pour les
consommateurs
il se lance en 2010 et en 30 jours il
vend des stocks qui savait préparer pour
l'année entière mais il avait anticipé
aussi il laisse déjà et ça un message
préparé pour laisser 20 000 clients à
liste d'attente
ils sont vraiment du succès ils sont ni
les émotions chacune au bon moment
tellement de succès qu'en 2015 ils sont
élus l'entreprise la plus innovatrice au
monde aujourd'hui ils sont 7% des parts
de marché pour cet assigner et la valeur
de leur au marché de leur entreprise et
de plus d'un milliard ces quatre
étudiants
innover c'est décidé on innove avec nos
émotions c'est une question du bon
timing les bons émotions au bon moment
vous êtes tous des innovateurs des
démons d'aujourd'hui
je suis convaincue
que si vous ne laissez pas la peur vous
paralysez vous s'arrêtez si vous restez
confiant à vous à vos idées un vos rêves
ne laissant que personne vous dise non
et juste après vous préparez sans vous
décourager tous les problèmes que vous
allez devoir surmonter
vous innoverrez avec succès le reste de
votre vie
merci